[Music]
as most americans wait to get the covert
vaccine we are learning about
accusations that some wealthy
and well-connected people are trying to
cut the line in florida officials are
investigating reports at a luxury
assisted living facility
offered and vaccinated its board members
and wealthy donors out of turn
well manuel bahrkos is at a vaccine
distribution site
in miami gardens with more on the story
good morning to you men well we can see
the cars lining up already
that's right so you know the saying
money talks well we should point out
that states are trying to clamp down on
improper distribution but the reports of
people skipping the line come as you
note
people here waiting in long lines for
the vaccine
there are people dealing with
registration websites that keep failing
or phone lines that are jammed
or are essential workers who are not
part of the first round
of shots for those teachers that are not
virtual
they should have a priority to vaccinate
miami teacher carl hernandez-matz is the
president of the largest teachers union
in the southeastern united states
teachers currently under 65 are not
eligible to get the vaccine in florida
and it's unclear when they will be just
as essential workers like firefighters
and police are being prioritized so
should have teachers
it's up to individual states to
determine who gets the vaccine
and when the frustration comes amid
reports
some wealthy americans are trying to get
vaccinated before they are eligible
and in some cases may have been
successful a state and federal
investigation is underway after morse
life health system in west palm beach
florida
was accused of giving vaccines to its
rich donors
who do not live at its assisted living
facility
it was reportedly organized by two new
york real estate moguls
on the board of directors you have
basically given the vaccine
to hundreds and hundreds of different
private providers
and you're trusting that they're going
to do the right thing
state representative omaree hardy
oversees the district where morse life
health is located
it just goes to show that there's been
one pandemic
for the ridge and there's been another
pandemic for the rest of us who are not
rich and well connected
i have an acquaintance who was able
to just log on on the new jersey site
who's not a high-risk person and go get
a vaccine
dr edward goldberg is a concierge doctor
in new york city
that means his patients pay him a fee of
20 thousand dollars a year
which covers their personalized care
it's really more
people who aren't my existing patients
i'm getting a lot of phone calls from
people
like you're a concierge doctor i will
join if you will come to my home and
give me a covet vaccine
what do you tell them what i tell people
is if they are part of my practice i
will let them know immediately when
they're eligible but i really
don't have the ability to adjust
the waiting list people are just used to
being able to get their way when they
have privilege and wealth
last month cbs news spoke with beverly
hills doctor essen ali
who told us several dozen people offered
to pay him to cut the vaccine line
he told them no now he says he's been
hearing of people getting the vaccine
through their hospital or government
connections people are willing to do
what it takes to get this vaccine
in california the state medical board
recently warned that providers who do
not properly distribute and administer
the vaccine
could have their license revoked earlier
this month
new york governor andrew cuomo also said
he planned to introduce legislation
that would make it a crime to help
someone skip the vaccine line
people of means are used to being able
to get their hands on that resource by
paying
more money holly fernandes lynch is an
assistant professor of medical ethics at
the university of pennsylvania
she pointed out the wealthy often have
more means to protect
against covid people who are most
vulnerable to covid
are racial and ethnic minorities and it
has nothing to do with
you know biology or genetics or any of
that it has to do with how those
features correlate with other types of
inequity in our country in terms of what
types of jobs people have
where people are living is our health
care system set up
where clearly it's an advantage to have
money
when it comes to prioritizing yourself
certainly
the vaccine is one teeny tiny example of
that
this is just one tiny microcosm of the
really really disturbing inequity that
we see in the american health care
system
we reached out to morse life the
facility in west palm beach
as well as a representative of the two
real estate moguls who are accused of
helping their wealthy friends
get the vaccine so far we have not heard
back
from either tony all right manny thank
you very much no additional comments
next slide detail
no no no i mean i just think it's it's
very scary because everybody wants it
yeah you know and they're trying to work
out the system so that everybody can get
it equitable everybody should be
part of a wealthy and well-connected
entity called the united states
government
yeah they should be taking care of us on
this front and hospitals who who want to
take money to give things out early
should resist that urge nobody i know
thinks that's a good idea no it's a bad
idea and you're not qualified
agreed we have consensus